hier ich hab so was geht hier so adriani
und heute gibt es ein paar tränchen rang
kubicki auf dem hd ich habe einfach bock
drauf dass wir ein bisschen feiern mit
musik im hintergrund und wahrscheinlich
weil ich so viele quatschen sondern
einfach mein spiel ein bisschen aufbauen
weil letzter zeit bin ich ja ein
bisschen schlechter geworden
muss ich eigentlich ehrlich gesagt schon
sagen und dabei hab ich jetzt einfach
mal meine musik dabei ist es irgendwie
irgendwie cool das was hatten feiern
konnten
klar das ist immer ärgerlich weil die
musik zu laut sein kann aber es ist
irgendwie irgendwie cool an der tüte nix
einnahmen wir können trotzdem töten
leute und getrocknet bevor irgendwelche
großen töne spucken heute erstmal
wirklich erledigen oh gott das ist
nämlich jetzt ziemlich klein gegeben
aber dann hat er wirklich sehr gut
aufgeholt
ich muss man ihm lassen auch wenn er nix
einen namen hat was wir natürlich
verurteilen
als eigentliche hier zwei mittlerweile
ich meint mittlerweile ist er alles
gleich community auf komme auch ein
halbes herz hat er mag er aber den holen
wir uns die nächsten kämpfe leute ich
hoffe es zumindest aber ich zeige es
eigentlich echt nicht so oft nur wieder
gestern vorgestern ein bisschen und ich
habe das eigentlich dann auch er so in
den in den abendstunden das nicht ob die
leute besser oder schlechter leute
besser oder schlechter sind
ja er hat mir an sich glaube ich wieder
die besten hits gegeben
gott werde mich nächste gekommen
angedeutete britischen hier wie gremium
simon und alle mit ihrem sch fehler
konzentrieren
junge einig hat mir gefehlt jetzt kann
natürlich rennen
ich weiß habe ich keine teile mehr
glaubt auch sehr jungen da könnt ihr mir
liebend gerne mal helfen hier
ich hab's fing ja ihr könnt wollen ihn
nur kings ich hab mir auch folge voll
die guten projekts gegeben und meinen
wahrscheinlich
das sind die größten mist kinder nur
ping dass er mir gerade die ganzen
projekts gibt finde ich also das werde
ich nur rennen weil den der typ verdient
es richtig dass man ihn ab fakt der
person müsste ist und hier so auf und
ich bin ganz gut weil ich nix einnahme
ab runde
da könnte schon wieder fragen die mir
mal
gehen wir mal anlass uns post wemmer zu
nennen lasst uns bloß traditionellen
verdammte kacke laster auf fick dich
hundezone residenz du bist ein richtige
mistet bahn riskieren weil ich muss mal
wieder aufnehmen
ok dann hört er wenn du siehst du bist
die letzte rate diese auf diesem
planeten gibt den ich so ne und
probieren diesmal zu gewinnen und nicht
mit etlichen hundert sind klatschen zu
lassen
ja und spaß so was wenn man in residence
heiß und schreibt nur ping wenn es
irgendwo von basiert und das irgendwie
bahn war erst dann mögen
aber es ist doch hat er immer ähnlich
viele oder gott ich bin mit der angel
echt nicht so gut aber ihr müsst mir
unbedingt tipps geben wie ich meine
britt reid erhöhe
jetzt habe ich wenigstens 35 prozent
aber an sich geht da noch so viel mehr
und ich hatte irgendwie echt gerne ein
paar tipps so wie ich das mache
der gestern mit - nutzen verbunden
worden was one of two mode aber gespielt
und ja man darf zb mit rein springen
aber der probiert immer die graffitis
oder so eine kacke hier hat er mir
erzählt zu kriegen also der probiert
halt in trier mit viel glück wünscht
was hast du denn fall gefallen dafür
dass du nicht schreibt ich hasse das ich
hasse das so sehr in altem eine fts sind
auch ziemlich los ich hasse das wenn
leute sofort meinen von wegen öl du bist
gemütlich würste youtube ist ja ich
nicke mich aber damit du hast mich
schreibst du brain halter das macht mich
das traurig egal wir schauen mal den ich
so auch erfolgreich sein kann
ich hoffe es sehr ich habe heute so ein
zeitplan
ich muss lernen okay das lied passt ja
mal gar nicht ich will böse kampf oder
musik aufwartet du mal bitte bitte die
musik passt nämlich nicht das ist eine
schande natürlich wenn man es gerade gar
nicht ich es aber dass definitiv ein
richtiger lappen okay dafür tut mir
jetzt hoffe ich doch mal sehr schwach
sportlicher wert gelegt oder oder er hat
mich schon normal hätte es nicht auf
jeden fall richtig eklige zeitgenossen
hätten sie sogar teleportiert auch alter
was geben hier etliche zeitgenossen hier
teilweise leider auf dem server also auf
ich bin toll und ich bin der beste und
niemand spielt einfach nur mal so ein
bisschen celik und probiert es zu
verbessern oder sonst was
nein die sind natürlich alle die
entlassen
das werde ich immer sich irgendwie
eloquent wäre oder wenn man dokument
heißt und sich gerade die scala sofort
an
jetzt kann ich wenn ich hab einfach bin
jemand der voll hohes elo ass oder so
könnte sein aber wir machen einfach ganz
billig gehalten ist es gar nicht so
darauf fokussiert jeden kampf unbedingt
zu gewinnen ich würde es natürlich
passieren
das sind meine bogen durch was sie
gerade gestorben
genug ein getötet das verstehe ich jetzt
gerade gar nicht aber irgendwie es hat
auch mit einem bogen gesprochen alter
die leute sind immer so deplatziert ist
voll der ecke bog ich will ein bisschen
ruhig spielen das ist voll der eklige
back finde wenn die leute so deplatziert
sind ja kann ich mal wieder musik laufen
soundcloud du dummes drecks plattform
wesen beziehungsweise interpreten dieser
ewig fiel nichts an ihren tracks inc
hastig alle ok gucken wir
zusammenbekommen achten sich kein
kritiker ländlich haye geht doch schläge
wenig treffer dafür ja gut natürlich
habe ich jetzt gerade viel wie kritisch
aber ich frage mich wie ist die perfekte
taktik so ich will möglich also
natürlich möglichst viele christ aber
auch viele hits ob sie das wort offen
sieht das verein lässt ich meine viele
von euch sind wahrscheinlich ziemlich
cool und vpn können wir da irgendwelche
tipps geben soll
also muss wahrscheinlich natürlich den
first hit landen
aber ich frage mich jemand dann wenn man
jemanden kortmann straif doch das
schreiben ist doch um die leute herum
laufen und so vom boden aus schlagen
oder kann man überhaupt keine combo mit
krebs geben ich weiß echt nicht oder
hüpft man dann so um die leute herum
ich weiß es nicht mit sven schon wieder
derselbe tut was kommt jetzt schreibt
irgendwas kann ich mich selbst aufregend
wobei gut hätten ja nicht mehr aufgeregt
dass er das amt das er mit diese lex
alter ich habe wie ich hab so ich dir
niedrigen fps durch solche niedrigen fps
wenn ihr so kämpfe das eine schande aber
ich habe mir dass wir den lp mit sven hd
noch schnell sein können aber hier
vorbereitungen für wahr werden demnächst
natürlich aufgenommen
mit dem liu jia also werden aufgenommen
und aufgenommen ich verstehe also
aufgenommen im sinne von weitergeführt
bzw begonnen
oh gott aids war so knapp habe sie dafür
auf jeden fall wie wir hier die trade
also liebend gerne tipps von euch
insofern möglich werde mich definitiv
interessieren
irgendwie ist ich habe auch so viele
mittlerweile ist jeder irgendwie so ein
bisschen gut da fackelt alte heil bisher
zum mein gott oh ich war man kann gar
nicht schillig pvp spielen ein ründchen
machen wir noch vielleicht warten wir
mal ein bisschen dass wir nicht schon
wieder gegen den lp mit wenden hier
kämpfen
ich will nicht achte er da brauchen wir
endlich ein bisschen mit 560 ja gut das
heißt ja nicht viel ich mein können wir
auch mehr elo haben wenn ich öfter
spielen würde aber wir haben mal ein
gegner das natürlich schön
ich finde aber ganz entspannt gerade
muss ich sagen
also ich habe eigentlich nur relativ
wenig zeit gehabt immer aufnehmen und
das ist jetzt aber gar nicht so
gezwungen oder sowas hier die aufnahme
sondern macht viel spaß und schoss auf
seite jetzt nehme ich den spaß den ich
während der aufnahme hatte in dem ihr
schreibt bis zu schlecht zu im pvp wird
mir viel besser sonst bist du kann ich
so gut wie david johnston extra das
schreibt ihr doch alle teams wird es
nicht schreiben ihr kleine arschlöcher 8
ich weiß dass es umso ein teleport gibt
in den leute benutzen so um sich zum
beispiel bei sg am anfang zu den kisten
habe ich eine schlechte connection
schlechte gemerkt hat und sich zb bei sg
am anfang zu den zu den kisten zu stehen
das weiß ein halbes herz aber schon
wieder um sich zu gott ey das ist
wirklich schwierig komplette sätze zu
reden und zu zocken
ich weiß dass es einen weg gibt mit dem
man sich zum beispiel bei sg in die
mittel tieren kann aber erst eine
schlechte connection von einer denkt man
dass er einfach lecken wird komm schon
also liebend gerne wie gesagt oh gott
jetzt also kritik für meine tv skills
beziehungsweise nichts gilt gerne in die
kommentare
ok ok schade dass wenig traurig also
es schade dass ich jetzt sagen schade
dass sich mit einer verlorenen runde
aufhöre
aber dann spielt er noch nach schadet
cool wenn ich jetzt gerne meine revanche
gegen den typen von timm gatter wir
waren echt sehr ausgeglichen aber ich
glaube ich muss mich auch nochmal
hardwaremäßig vor war ein bisschen
aufbauen ich glaube ich kann man neue
grafikkarte und ich muss einfach mal
meine ssd und somit leer räumen
vielleicht langsam auch wenn ich meinen
pc ein bisschen neu aufsetzen
ohne irgendeine große kultur
nachzukarten weil ich meine früher lief
das auch quasi ohne probleme und wird
jetzt was ich bin absolut wie du glaubst
bringt nicht viel wenn er regeneriert
hier
nice ok sehr schön im smi war die angel
gut eingesetzt und jetzt muss ich mir
noch einen von den zweikämpfen hier
gewinnen und da hab ich das ding
gerissen bitte kommt zurück mit dieser
mir die daumen treffen können
die partie entschied den ersten hit von
unten kriegen können aha verdammt eng
ich weiß noch wie mal jemand nach einem
kampf in dem ich denjenigen glaube ich
sogar natürlich auch nach dem kampf in
dem ich denjenigen sogar besiegt habe
hat mögliche hatte der typ beschrieben
omg
du hast null game ich habe mir so viel
dreck an allen möglichen schmerzhaften
ging dies gibt da wir so halte er
schreibt einmal wirklich omg
du hast null rott aim und das ist
ungefähr so alles was ich verachte also
erstmal so irgendwie so die leute so zu
provozieren nachdem man auch noch
verloren hatte das ist schon eine
schande und dann auch noch das vokabular
0 j m
hat mich dann schon ein bisschen er
macht das gerade gut
ich glaube ich passe jetzt mal ein
bisschen ausprobieren eine feile wieder
auf zusammen die gerade verschossen habe
probiert mein rating zu verbessern und
leute ganz egal ob ich jetzt gewinne
oder nicht ich werde irgendwie muss ich
finde es ist ganz authentisch so besser
als hier im einfachen 3000 runden
aufzunehmen die man gewinnt bitte dass
ich aus berlin ist sein ansehen direkt
gesunken wieder damals von heute ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen obwohl ich
jetzt nicht komplett rasiert habe aber
es war trotzdem spannend fand ich meine
ich halte meine chance wir können selbst
entscheiden ob es euch gefallen hat oder
nicht lässt man leichter wenn das euch
gefallen hat und dann sehen wir mal
nicht mal wieder macht's gut